je vous dis en vétérans loin des
machines où figure une écoute et voilà
le méchant loup
c'est là que tout a commencé lorsque
j'avais 19 ans je n'ai joué ce soir vers
10h à peu près et je n'avais qu'à
traverser la place pour aller à mon
deuxième rendez vous du soir à minuit
alors ici du temps où ça s'appelait vie
clusaz c'est là où j'ai fait mes débuts
dans le monde merveilleux du
café-théâtre et puis du music-hall
vraiment professionnel en voiture
professionnels juliette a mis une
dizaine d'années n'ont pas à le devenir
accepter de l'être seulement aujourd'hui
avec un disque et l'engagement des mois
au théâtre de dix heures à paris
c'est une évidence le fait d'essayer en
tout cas je pense que c'est envisagé
quelques concessions c'est apprendre des
chutes et des attitudes profite un peu
plus professionnel quoi c'est à dire des
d'état une gestion d'image comme on
monte un répertoire enfin plein de plein
de choses comme ça à côté vraiment delà
de la représentation le travail qui se
fait autour c'est avait pire philippe
l'éminence grise de jean guidoni que
juliette met en scène ce deuxième acte
de sa carrière une gestation qui va
peut-être tout changé sauf son ancrage à
toulouse
m6 nouvelles quant au riz de tango sans
quelque chose d'anachronique moi j'aime
bien aussi mélanger des choses très
différentes
voilà pourquoi pas la périchole
d'offenbach il faut bien le dire sur la
place de la périchole la culture c'est
julien sait qu'en elle-même
il était très juste raison qu'une riche
de quelques chansons votre type d'homme
martial sur né avec
les petits enfants raconte je ne sais
trop quoi
des histoires l'eurasie borné en
regardant pousser mes doigts